liz trust is just walking into the
chamber now
on the 20th of may uh mr speaker the
previous secretary wrote to the health
minister let's bring in our political
editor beth rigby who's here in the
studio with me um well there she is what
one one resource going through her mind
beth
well i think what you would expect in
the chamber today is for today at least
she'll get maximum support from the back
benches that want to cheer her in and
cheer her on
what will her style be compared to boris
johnson well i understand uh that she
will try to be statesmanlike it's if you
like gone are the days of boris johnson
making japes and there will be a more
serious tone from the new prime minister
focusing on issues that i'm sure label
will want to talk about too which is the
cost of living the energy crisis and the
nhs and i think she'll lean in uh to the
theme of uh the campaign where she'll
kind of be i may not be the slickest
performer i mean that was her sort of
rift against rishi sunak but i am
someone that understands what people of
the country need i think that will be uh
the sense that we'll get from her from
labour as lucy powell was talking about
i imagine that they will be pressing her
on this double plan to not only help on
energy bills but to cut taxes at a time
uh when the economy might need tax
revenues to fund this huge
energy package which she is going to
announce uh tomorrow so it's going to be
very interesting to see the dynamics
between liz trust and kirsten i think
there's some quiet confidence on the
labour benches that she'll be an easier
person to beat them
and i know she will want to ensure that
any statements will be made in the house
first
we now come to number one
and we start with
paul hamilton
pauletta
[Applause]
mr speaker
i'm honored to take my place as prime
minister in this house
and to take on responsibility as a vital
time for our country
i am determined to deliver for everybody
across our united kingdom
i will work constructively with all
members of this house to tackle the
challenges we face
mr speaker this morning i had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you mr speaker can i warmly
welcome the prime minister to her place
it's her first pmq and it's also mine
yeah yeah yeah in a leaked audio tape
the prime minister is heard saying that
british workers need to put in more
grafts and they and that they are
lacking in skill and application
she also wants to take away their basic
workers rights
in my erdington constituency the latest
figures from the commons library show
that children over 7 000 households are
living in child poverty and that 68
of those households have working parents
so does the prime minister believe that
thousands of working parents on low
income in my community should just put
in more grafts
i congratulate the honourable lady on
her first prime minister's question
and what i am determined to do as prime
minister is to make sure we have an
economy with high wages and high skilled
jobs and the way the way i will achieve
that
is through reducing taxes on people
across our country and boosting economic
growth that is the way that we will make
sure we get the investment and the jobs
that people deserve
[Applause]
i want to warmly congratulate my right
of honorable friend on becoming the
third woman prime minister
i wish her welcome apprenticeship and i
want to ask her about pumps today
a pub restaurant in my constituency in
barnet got in touch with me to say they
were struggling to find an energy
supplier and the quotes they had got
hold of show that they would be paying a
600
increase in their bill to 320 000 pounds
they can't survive that will she ensure
her plan to tackle the energy price
crisis helps businesses in the
hospitality sector which our communities
value so much
well my right honourable friend is
absolutely right
the hospitality industry is vital and i
will make sure
in our energy plan that will help
support businesses and people with the
immediate
price crisis
as well as making sure there are
long-term supplies available will help
businesses as well as helping individual
households
we now come to the leader of the
opposition kia stammer
thank you mr speaker can i congratulate
the prime minister on her appointment
[Music]
when when she said when she said in her
leadership campaign that she was against
windfall taxes
did she mean it yeah
well i thank the uh right honourable
gentleman for his welcome i hope that we
will be able to work together
particularly on areas we agree on
and i know that we have had strong
support from the opposition in opposing
vladimir putin's appalling war in
ukraine and i want us to continue to
stand up to that appalling russian
aggression that has led to the energy
crisis we face now
i am against a windfall tax i believe it
is the wrong thing to be me to be
putting
companies off investing in the united
kingdom just when we need to be growing
the economy
mr speaker thank you for the answer i
ask because the treasury estimates are
that the energy producers will make 170
billion pounds in excess profits over
the next two years
the prime minister knows she's no choice
but to back an energy price freeze
but it won't be cheap and the real
choice
the political choice is
who is going to pay
is she really telling us that she's
going to leave these vast excess profits
on the table
and make working people put the bill for
decades to come
well i understand that people across our
country are struggling with the cost of
living and they're struggling with their
energy bills and that is why i as prime
minister will take immediate action to
help people with the cost of their
energy bills and i will be making an
announcement
to this house on that tomorrow
and giving people certainty to make sure
that they are able to get through this
winter
and be able to have the energy supplies
and be able to afford it but we can't
just deal with today's problem we can't
just put a sticking plaster on it what
we need to do is increase our energy
supplies long term and that is why we
will open up more supply in the north
sea which the honorable gentleman has
opposed that is why we will build more
nuclear power stations which the labour
party didn't do when they were in office
and that is why we will get on with
delivering the supply as well as helping
people through the winter
well i look forward to tomorrow's
statement but the money's got to come
from somewhere
and she she knows that every single
pound in excess profits she chooses not
to tax is an extra pound on borrowing
that working people will be forced to
pay back for decades to come
more borrowing than is needed that's the
true cost of her choice
to protect oil and gas profits isn't it
mr speaker the reality is that this
country will not be able to tax its way
to growth
the way the way we will grow our economy
is by attracting investment keeping
taxes low delivering the reforms to
build projects quicker that is the way
that we will create jobs and
opportunities across our country
so mr speaker her first act as prime
minister
is to borrow more than is needed because
she won't touch excess oil and gas
profits
on that topic how much would her planned
corporation tax cut hand out to
companies
the right honourable gentleman is
looking at this in the wrong way the
last time
[Applause]
the last time
we cut corporation tax
we attracted more revenue
into the exchequer because more
companies wanted to base themselves in
britain more countries wanted to invest
more companies wanted to invest in our
country
and if taxes are put up
and raised to the same level as france
which is what the current proposal is
and which i will change as prime
minister
that will put off investors it will put
off
those companies investing our economy
and ultimately that will mean fewer jobs
less growth and less opportunities
across our country
[Applause]
mr speaker it's extraordinary that not
only is the prime minister refusing to
extend the windfall tax she's also
choosing to have the water companies
polluting our beaches a tax cut
[Music]
she's choosing
she's choosing
she's choosing to have the banks
attackers
she's choosing to hand the banks a tax
cut add it all together
and companies that are already doing
well are getting a 17 billion pound tax
cut yeah while working people pay for
the cost of living crisis
stroke victims wait an hour for an
ambulance and criminals walk the streets
with impunity
families and public services need every
penny they can get how on earth does she
think that now is the right time to
protect shell's profits and give amazon
a tax break
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm on the side
of people who work hard and do the right
thing
that is why we will reverse the national
insurance increase and that is why we
will keep corporation tax low because
ultimately we want investment right
across our country
we want new jobs and new opportunities
and that is what i will deliver as prime
minister
[Applause]
mr speaker the prime minister claims to
be breaking orthodoxy but the reality is
she's reheating george osborne's failed
corporation tax plan
protecting oil and gas profits and
forcing working people to pay the bill
she's the fourth tory prime minister in
six years the face at the top may change
but the story remains the same
there is nothing new about the tory
fantasy of trickle-down economics
nothing new about this tory prime
minister who nodded through every single
decision that got us into this mess and
now says how terrible it is
and can't she see
there's nothing new about a tory prime
minister who when asked who pays
says it's you
the working people of britain
well there's nothing new about a labour
leader who is calling for more
it's the taxes old same old tax and
spend
what i am about
is about reducing taxes
getting our economy growing
getting investment getting new jobs for
people right across the country i'm
afraid to say the right honorable
gentleman doesn't understand aspiration
he doesn't understand opportunity
he doesn't understand that people want
to keep more of it their own money and
that is what i will deliver as prime
minister
i will take immediate action to help
people with their energy bills but also
secure our long-term energy supply i
will take immediate action to make sure
we have lower taxes and we grow the
economy and that way i will ensure we
have a positive future for our country
and we get britain moving
thank you mr speaker and firstly can i
congratulate my right honourable friend
the pride the prime minister for a
successful campaign and to become our
party leader in the prime minister of
the united kingdom
mr speaker it is right and proper that
the government focuses its attention on
rising energy costs for households
across the country but as we've heard
businesses big and small are exposed to
horrific energy price increases with no
restraint provided by the domestic
energy price cap and no support from
government so far
for the sake of businesses in west
cornwall and on city the jobs they
provide and the economy as a whole
what can my friend the right honourable
prime minister due to easy energy costs
facing our businesses
well my my honorable friend is right we
do need to address the issues businesses
face
and the package that we will be
announcing tomorrow will do just that
leader of the smp ian blackford
thank you mr speaker and i'm sure the
thoughts and prayers of everyone in this
house will be with the families that
were caught up in the terrible shooting
over recess and kylo mcaulish and indeed
in liverpool as well and we trust that
the families will be fully supported
mr speaker let me congratulate the prime
minister and her family on her
appointment
but i'm sorry to say that her reputation
for straight talking is falling apart at
the first pmqs
after nine questions
she's still not told us
who will pay for her energy plan
prime minister today the public are
waiting to find out the response to the
economic crisis and they want answers so
will the prime minister finally answer
two very simple questions
will she freeze energy prices at their
current levels and will it be fed for by
a windfall tax yes or no
well no it won't be paid for by a
windfall tax i don't believe we can tax
our way to growth
and
what i want to see is i want to see us
using more of our uk energy supply
including more oil and gas from the
north sea and nuclear and nuclear power
in scotland as well and i hope i can
count on the snp support for that
[Applause]
well thank you
thank you mr speaker can i say that
on her first full day as prime minister
she has failed to rule out
failed to rule
let's out the next question in blackfoot
the prime minister may have changed mr
speaker but it's the same all been
shouted down by the attorney
on her first full day as prime minister
she's failed to rule out a trust tax on
household and businesses
instead of targeting the profits of
massive corporations with a windfall tax
the prime minister plan appeared to be a
decade-long raid on the bank accounts of
ordinary taxpayers these costs must not
be passed on to consumers and businesses
by deferring bills
government must announce an enhanced
windfall profits tax making sure that
those oil and gas producers pay their
fair share from excess profits does the
prime minister understand that her first
act as prime minister will now define
her a trust tax that household and
businesses will be paying for years to
come well i'm not quite sure what the uh
right horrible gentleman's position is
because on one hand he doesn't seem to
want oil and gas extraction from the
north sea and on the other hand he wants
them to pay more taxes why does he make
up his mind
[Applause]
uh thank you mr speaker can i also
warmly welcome my right honourable
friend to uh
as uh prime minister uh mr speaker
scottish power
bulb and eon just three of many energy
suppliers that say they provide 100
renewable electricity
yet constituents of mine in west austin
are baffled that the energy regulator
allows those prices to rise on par with
oil and gas
would my right honourable friend confirm
that she is on the side of the consumer
in her energy policy that we'll hear
from tomorrow yeah yeah
well i certainly am on the side of
consumer and we need to make sure
that we deal with all of the issues
in the energy market and the way that
energy is regulated and i will certainly
be saying more about this tomorrow
thank you mr speaker the prime minister
should know by now that uh many people
in the north of ireland are starving and
freezing in their homes we need a
tailored solution for northern ireland
but that's much harder to achieve
because the dup are refusing to form a
government at stormont the new prime
minister has a choice to make she can
either be on the side of the dup or on
the side of struggling people in
northern ireland so whose side is she on
well mr speaker i i want to work with
all of the parties in northern ireland
to get the executive and the assembly
back up and running so we can
collectively
deliver for the people of northern
ireland but in order to do that we do
need to fix the issues of the northern
ireland protocol which has
damaged the balance between the
communities in northern ireland i'm
determined to get on with doing that and
i'm determined to work with all parties
to find that resolution
theresa may thank you mr speaker may i
congratulate my right honourable friend
and welcome her to her position as the
third
can i ask my right honourable friend why
does she think it is that all three
female prime ministers have been
conservative
[Applause]
well i i thank my right honorable
friend for her fantastic question i look
forward to calling on her advice
from her time in office as i start as i
start my work as i start my work as
prime minister it is it is quite
extraordinary isn't it that there
doesn't seem to be
the ability in the labour party to find
a
a female leader indeed a leader who
doesn't come from north london yeah
i don't know what it is
thank you mr speaker can i also
congratulate the prime minister on her
appointment mr speaker inflation is at a
40-year high the nhs is on its knees
with 6.6 million people waiting for
treatment
thousands of victims of sexual offenses
and violent crime are waiting for
justice not to mention passport delays a
summer of chaos in our airports and our
beaches covered in sewage the prime
minister has served in every one of the
conservative governments responsible for
this mess so why should the british
public trust her to clean up the mess
that she's helped create
i'm determined that we deal with the
issues facing us as a nation we do have
problems with our energy supply due to
the appalling war being perpetrated by
putin in ukraine that is why i will take
immediate action to deal with the energy
crisis
my chancellor will take immediate action
to reduce taxes and make sure we are
growing our economy and our new health
secretary who is also the deputy prime
minister
will be taking immediate action to make
sure people are able to get appointments
with their gp and proper nhs services
part of the house of peter bottomlet
[Applause]
all sides of the house should wish to
help the prime minister be successful in
tackling the problems facing the country
when i raised one of them with the
former prime minister in july he said i
could talk to the housing minister but
the housing minister retired after 17
minutes of hearing that
[Laughter]
can i ask the prime minister
to look to see why the planning
inspectorate are able to overturn
council's planned protections for green
lungs and will she look at what's
happening to the goring gap the a 259 in
worthing west and in south downs
constituency because local councils have
no role if they can't protect what
matters most to them
well i am a bit concerned about offering
the honourable gentleman a meeting with
the housing minister
in case in case any ill should befall
should before him but uh
look
my my honourable friend is right uh
there is not enough power in local hands
at the moment it is too easy for local
councils to be overruled by the planning
inspectorate and that is certainly an
issue that i'm expecting my secretary of
state for housing to look at anna bardel
thank you very much mr speaker according
to the prime minister's new deputy prime
minister one of the things that
qualified her most for being pm and was
one of her greatest achievements was the
reintroduction of beavers now i'm all
for the beavers but given her
flip-flopping on brexit and giving her
inability to understand global affairs
how can constituents like mine like waz
abbas whose energy prices are going to
go from seven to thirty seven thousand
pounds a year or broad text in
livingston who are going to go from 50
to 250 000 pounds a month have any faith
that she can tackle the oncoming
humanitarian crisis is she going to come
out of her den and number 10 and take
real action or is she going to be as
useless and corrupt as her predecessor
[Music]
well i i am determined to tackle the
issues we face in energy and i look
forward uh to the scottish government
playing their part by building new
nuclear power stations
can i just say i want a nice opponent
that was not a good example i certainly
don't want to use corrupt being used
against the new prime minister and i'm
sure there are no members just
i'm sure they're on one but we'll
withdraw it
just withdraw the
sometimes sometimes the truth hurts but
i'm happy
who am i sure
right
victoria atkins
thank you mr speaker may i warmly
congratulate my writingal friend may i
welcome her to her place but may i also
wish her the very best in the heavy
responsibilities she now bears
around one and a half million households
across the countryside rely on heating
oil in order to keep their homes warm
absolutely and to cook their meals
they have faced price rises of around
130
in recent months and they are not part
of the energy price cap
as rumors abound about what tomorrow's
statement may hold will my right
honourable friend confirm that those one
and a half million households many of
them in rural areas such as my own
constituency will be specifically
included
in any muted ideas about an energy price
freeze
well my my honourable friend is right
and many of my constituents too
rely on heating oil
for their fuel and we need to make sure
that we are looking after everybody
in this very very difficult winter that
we're facing
martinday
thank you mr speaker members may be
familiar with the work of bones firm
valentine's castings an iron foundry in
operation since the 1820s which in
recent years has done much work around
the parliamentary estate
without the protection of an energy
price gap this specialist sme is
witnessing unaffordable costs with bills
rising from thirteen thousand two
hundred and twenty thousand per month
heavy energy users face a
disproportionate burden and clearly need
more support than other businesses what
will the pm do to protect our
strategically important and
energy-intensive industries
[Music]
i very strongly agree with the
honourable gentleman that there are
strategic industries that we need to
make sure who use a lot of energy
we need to do all we can to help them
become more energy efficient but we also
need to make sure that they're able to
remain competitive in the global
marketplace and that is certainly
something the energy secretary is
looking at in preparing this package
dr kieran
congratulations prime minister on her
appointment and tell her i know my
constituents wanted to succeed at a
difficult time outside of the immediate
challenges of energy and inflation
leveling up remains a priority for them
one way to demonstrate her commitment to
leveling up would be to choose a town
like crew to host great british railways
[Music]
[Applause]
can she ensure that leveling up is at
the heart of that decision
crew is of course a great railway town
uh my honourable friend is absolutely
right i'm not gonna pre-judge the
decision that will be made but what i
will be doing as prime minister is
absolutely focusing on levelling up and
making sure we're attracting the
investment and grace into parts of this
country that have been left behind so
they have their fair share of
opportunity
alex davis joe mr speaker the new prime
minister is now finally imposed but make
no mistake she does not have the support
of the british public she can't even
rely on the backing of her own mps and
people in pontepre will never forget
that she played a key role in a
government that failed millions so will
she now finally do the right and decent
thing and call a general election
[Applause]
mr speaker
[Applause]
mr speaker
as a as a country
we are facing
a very serious crisis in energy caused
by putin's war in ukraine we are
faithful
one of the members for stoke is getting
very carried away and i know he's a
former teacher he wants to show better
behavior than he's showing at the moment
come on prime minister
mr speaker we are we are facing very
serious issues as a country
uh
uh partly as a result of the aftermath
of cavid partly as a result of putin's
war in ukraine what the british people
want is they want a government that's
going to sort it out and that is what
that is what i'm determined to do as
prime minister
sort out the energy crisis get our
economy going make sure people can get
doctor's appointments that's what i'm
focused on
nick fletcher thank you mr speaker i
would like to congratulate my honourable
friend for positioning as prime minister
but i'd also like to thank you for the
support of my campaign to keep doncaster
sheffield airport
[Applause]
further writing to south yorkshire mayor
oliver coppad and peel holdings chairman
john whitaker to remind them of their
powers duties and responsibilities to
the people of south yorkshire and
myanmar and will she use the full weight
of her office on these decision makers
so as to keep our doncaster sheffield
airport open
[Applause]
well
regional airports including the
doncaster shefford airport are a vital
part of our economic growth and what i
will make sure is that the new transport
secretary is immediately onto this issue
uh and i know she is i can tell look
she's already contacting she's already
contacting the people in doncaster in
sheffield to make sure we do protect
this airport and we protect those that
vital infrastructure and connectivity
that helps our economy grow
hello morgan
thank you mr speaker and i'd also like
to welcome the prime minister to her new
post
during her leadership campaign she said
that waiting times for ambulances in her
rural norfolk constituency were
appalling and in north shropshire i
think many of my constituents would
agree with that statement across britain
waiting hours and hours for an ambulance
has become normal but instead of
focusing on this problem a leadership
fiasco and the conservatives have seen
three health secretaries in three months
will the prime minister get a grip on
this grave situation and commissioned
the cqc into investigating the causes of
and the solutions to the ambulance
services delays before the servicing
crisis
faces the additional pressures of an
oncoming winter
people should not have to wait as long
as they are for ambulance services and
my new health secretary is immediately
tackling this issue she's already laid
out her priorities and sorting out the
ambulance service is one of them
dave caroline
speaker can i also very warmly welcome
our new prime minister to her role and
indeed the whole of her front bench
this is september is childhood cancer
awareness month and as she knows cancer
is still the biggest killer of children
under the age of 14. so i wonder if she
could restate her government's
commitment to publish a cancer 10-year
strategy but also embedding a childhood
cancer mission at its very heart
mr speaker cancer is a devastating
disease and it's particularly
heartbreaking
when children
children have cancer and certainly
we will proceed with the strategy that
she talks about
and i know our new health secretary will
do all she can to help those children
with cancer so tony lloyd
thank you mr speaker on the theme of
children she will know from her time as
children as minister
that young lungs
exposed to cold and damp housing are
more likely to fall seriously ill and
possibly die now child poverty has been
growing during her ministerial time in
different offices will she give a solemn
pledge and no evasion that there will be
no child that will go to bed in a cold
damp house this winter and beyond
because the parents cannot afford to put
the heating on
but this
this is why it's so important that we do
tackle uh the issue of energy
and i will make sure
that people are able to afford their
energy bills at the same time as dealing
with the long-term supply issues to make
sure that we are resilient in energy and
never for get into this position again
mr speaker
it is the standard practice of the
european union
that when they can't get their way in
negotiations with the uk
they play for time
and wait for a new leader who they hope
will have a different view to their
predecessor
for the sake
for the sake of clarity would my right
honourable friend
confirm that it is the uk's preferred
option
to have a a negotiated settlement as far
as the northern ireland protocol is
concerned but if that is not forthcoming
then we will proceed with the protocol
bill that is currently going through
parliament
well well first of all can i thank my
right honourable friend for his service
as northern ireland secretary
he is absolutely right we need to
resolve the issue of the northern
ireland protocol my preference is for a
negotiated solution but it does have to
deliver
all of the things we set out in the
northern ireland protocol bill and what
we cannot allow is for this situation to
drift because my number one priority is
protecting the supremacy of the belfast
good friday agreement
rachel
the new hopkins minister tells us she
will deliver on the nhs well that's a
turn up for the books because after 12
years of conservatives driving our nhs
into the ground we have record waiting
lists people dying in ambulances outside
a e and nurses using food banks
so given the prime minister has served
in the past three conservative
governments on that watch
can she explain why we should trust her
to deliver
[Applause]
i mean i don't agree with the way she is
talking down our national health service
the fact is
the fact is that our health service did
brilliantly in tackling covert in
delivering the vaccine rollout and in
getting this country back on its feet
but we do face challenges now with the
backlog following kovid and this is why
the new health secretary is going to
work to address those challenges
jeremy right
speaker i congratulate my right
honourable friend on her appointment and
recognize her determination to address
the many urgent and difficult challenges
that face us now but would she accept
that one of those challenges is an
almost entirely unregulated online space
and which you accept too
that no responsible government can avoid
the need for excellent balanced sensible
regulation in this space and would you
therefore assure me that the online
safety bill will come back to this house
swiftly for us to consider further and
amend if necessary
well i can assure my honorable friend
that we will be proceeding uh with the
online safety bill there are some issues
that we need to deal with what i want to
make sure is that we protect
the under 18s from harm but we also make
sure free speech uh is allowed so there
may be some tweaks required but
certainly he is right that we need to
protect people's safety online
other days thank you mr speaker the
prime minister has been part of a
government for the past 12 years which
has been systematically letting down the
most vulnerable children in the country
the independent review of children's
social care published by the government
in may
describes the system as in need of a
total reset
the prime minister has said she wants to
deliver will she make a cast iron
commitment to deliver for our country's
most vulnerable children and published
the government's response to the
independent review and an action plan
for delivery before the end of the year
yes or no yeah
yes
thank you mr speaker
i would like to congratulate my right
honourable friend and her whole front
bench and wish them every success in the
new government
i'd particularly like to to thank my
right honourable friend for her
steadfast commitment to support for the
earliest years throughout the 12 years
that she and i have worked together for
three previous prime ministers so can i
ask her now to renew her commitment to
rolling out the best start for life to
give every baby the best chance at
leading a fulfilling life hey prime
minister my my right honourable friend
has done such a fantastic job
championing this issue developing the
policies
and i am committed to following through
and delivering for children because what
we know
is intervening early helping children
early is the best way to help those
children have a successful childhood and
ultimately a fulfilled life
that ends pmq's
well there we have it liz trust and her
first prime minister's questions
facing many questions about how she will
fund uh the problems that people are
facing with her energy bills how she
will freeze energy bills and whether
that money will come from taxation
whether it will come from borrowing
let's bring in uh our political editor
beth rigby beth very different wasn't it
from what we're used to over the last
couple of years with boris johnson um
less combative
in in many respects more ideological
less personal i thought it was more
ideological i thought it was more
enlightening in that
at long last you felt like there was a
prime minister's questions where instead
of trading rhetorical blows and
political attacks there were of course
political attacks but it was around
policy and differences over policy and
differences over ideology actually and
so quite straight questions quite
straight answers it was almost going
back to the old dividing lines of the
conservatives
versus labor as liz trust talked about
not wanting to put tax on business and
being a low taxation party that she was
going to hold the line on that she
wasn't going to
just give in to sort of public pressure
for tax rises and kierstama uh trying to
position her as
someone and a party on the side of
vested interests as he would put it
whereas labe was on the side of working
people now for labor that has been a
difficult line to draw under boris
johnson who of course took the red wall
and with brexit did position himself as
a a man who was on the side of working
people against the establishment if you
like you remember the way in which he
somehow quite stout deathly sort of
knitted together two very uh different
parts of the country and he knitted
together the kind of affluent shires of
the southeast as well as parts of the
traditionally working class red wall i
mean some of the things that kierstama
said he said
she's claiming to break orthodoxy but
the reality is she's reheating george
osborne's fell corporation tax plans he
said the conservative party will be
forcing working people to pay the bills
and he said the people who pay the bills
will be the working people of britain
and what is this all about it's about
this huge energy package tomorrow in
which liz truss
will announce we think a freeze or a cap
on wholesale prices of gas that means
that
electricity and energy providers can
pass that on to consumers an effective
cut to your bills we think it could be
capped at about two and a half thousand
pounds that's slightly up from the
freeze of
1971 back in april but it's much cheaper
than the average of three and a half
thousand pounds a year in october that
people are expecting but how will she
pay for it she's going to borrow yeah so
effectively the taxpayer in the long run
has to pay back government borrowing and
kierstama there was very clear he said
you're asking the taxpayer to foot that
bill instead of taxing companies a
windfall tax energy companies with these
excess profits of a prediction of 170
billion a year a year
uh so in the next couple of years now
jane
i know that the conservative party know
that that is controversial to try and
hold that line but ideologically liz
trust genuinely believes that low
taxation on business and not putting
taxes up for business will grow the
economy and she is consistent so this is
going to be
a clear dividing line between the
parties from labour's perspective i was
just talking to someone messaging them
about what they thought about that they
said we're very happy with this it's a
clear dividing line and as far as
they're concerned british people
don't like borrowing going up to fund
these things so liz trust clearly
prepared to do something that's publicly
really unpopular because it's what she
believes okay